You think for the first. Because we're going to have robots in our lives. And they're going to work with us.
They will take care of us. So for us to be able to trust them. We need to build a relationship with a robot.
And studies have shown that for us to work with robots.
We do need robots to understand our intention and emotion and not just what we say it's not just a command
and control kind of machine but our current.
No because they take your comments Literally right now
and they don't understand where you really mean you can say the same thing and in different tones
and with different gesture it will mean something totally different.
So I suppose you have a robot as taking care of the elderly and the robot says her are you doing today.
And you say you know I'm not sure the robot was if if the robot understand you literally just means you're not sure.
And the robot would just take off and walk away.
But what it really means what the ring turn really is that the patient or the other person is not feeling that great.
So the robot has to deduce that intention and the emotion from where you are saying how you are saying it.
And in order to be you better take you want to take care of us better control
but aren't you know they're not able to do that yet.
We're working on making them to do that which you actually want to introduce because I believe that in the future we're
going to need robots to take care of people to dig of the young to educate us to help us with a lot of work since we're
going to have them around us. I think it is important that they pay their more Hugh. Like in there empathy.
Why are we one robot to be intelligent great and intelligent robots need to have both the conative intelligence
and also emotional intelligence as well what we humans have
when we communicate with each other we use our emotional intelligence all the time
and that is indispensable for understanding each other and for robots to understand us.
They need to have that kind of emotional intelligence which is empathy because current groups are OK now.
Not yet not yet coral bots most of the time is still controlled by explicit commands for example you can tell
or about to a vacuum your room in some restaurants there are some robot waiters that will bring your food
and they are focus very narrowly on one task.
There are not that much more advanced than your vacuum cleaner now
or the rice cooker so Colonel those don't have that kind of emotional intelligence
but there are some robots who are putting this in some robots and there we start to see them. But why would it.
Because so that they can work with us better they can help us better if they need to take care of us they go about our
children our elderly they really need to understand I would truly intend emotion in order to take care of us saying if
you go to a hospital or there's a nurse and what a nurse that is is not just to take your temperature
and look at your vital signs but also talk to you and see how you're doing
and whether you need comforting whether you need water whether you need medicine at this point in time so that requires
emotional intelligence than they require empathy which.
Yes The robots are coming more into our lives into our daily lives and there will be more and more robots around us
and if they don't have the emotional intelligence they're more likely to make mistakes and you've heard us.
There are different guide to what kind of motion which expression. Should Just yes.
So for example the very first thing we're working on to for robots recognize includes whether the human is happy angry
sad or frustrated or hesitating or even this sense of humor.
One of my students is working on recognizing sense of humor stuck by. Because they're forcing. Yes yes. Just what.
The primary emotions are happiness a sad sadness anger or a neutral.
So you have to be able to tell whether the person is happy happy means that is fine are satisfied.
Not happy sad and needs help. Maybe frustrated angry.
So if the person angry at the robot the robot you have to do something in response. Which people rides. Right.
We're also working on for robots understand understand what sense of humor and sarcasm.
Are working on that because we use humor
and sarcasm in our daily communications to you know deflect the situation challenge
or to make a conversation we're friendly to make things go more smoothly so robots also need to learn to recognize that.
People's lives difficult indeed. India is a robot. Indeed so what.
Did you robots to watch a lot of comedy shows to learn sense of humor. You know so it's machine learning.
So we thing that we let the robot watch a lot of comedy shows and observe how people communicate with each other.
This is the so-called Big Data analytics and we use machine learning then they would be able to learn.
Actually we feel comedy shows and movies and yes
and people's are you know daily communications a lot of You Tube you Dio's you know we feed this to the robot.
Should also yes this is very it is important that is have shown that humans a few more related to a machine that has
some facial expressions way so that's why you know we don't really feel a connection to our refrigerator
or to our rice cooker because they're just machines but when you see a robot with acute phase and people start going.
They start talking to the robot in a more human way they go. So how are you doing and stuff like that.
So indeed the embodiment of a machine in the robotic body with facial expressions is important
and that is also important area and different researchers are working on that.
To allow a robot to generate a few appropriate facial expressions appropriate gesture for example to say hi
or to shake your hand and all that because of the tone of voice also from the rubble is very important to understand.
Should also be heard. OK. So if I say something like I'm really happy I'm going to work today.
That is you probably think I'm truly. Happy that I'm going to work today. Bye bye say.
I'm really happy I'm going to work today even though the words I speak are the same
but the emotions told different in the second case you know I'm being sarcastic
and I'm not really feeling like going to work so that tone of voice is important
and we used to own a voice in our way of expressing our meaning a lot.
So again the difference is we teach the robot to listen again to different kind of tone of voice.
So we show a robot examples of.
The same sentences in angry voice happy voice and nervous for days and frustrated voice
and we tell the rover look this is the kind of voice that expresses. Anger.
This is the kind of voice that expresses frustration and the robot runs how fast you.
Yes we do we do learn as children. So children robots. So children have Montalvo. Like a sensory input right.
Children perceive the world not just by what people are saying how they're saying but they also look at things.
So right now we're working towards enabling robot to have multiple sensory input as well.
So the robot now learns from the speech.
You're saying this is what you're saying but also learns from how you're seeing it.
We also a neighbor the robot to look at your facial expression
when you see it so that will of nobody robot robot to learn better. Yes indeed. Yes traumatized.
Yes I think robot trama I will say can be misled. If you you feed robot some information.
Like how would teach our children.
Robots can be traumatized to because they're machines so machine can have machine errors either from the embedded
coding the program. There were wrote or from the experience meaning the data they learn from it's different from.
They they were they. They can be led astray and they can have error us.
Is a different from human and it's different machine trauma.
I would say but but I mean children can be shushed because very well what about robots.
So robots can be dysfunctional because they are functioning properly if they have had a machine era
and if their errors caused by their experience then you can call that trauma
and they can be traumatized into this misbehaving indeed. It's going to be.
Grumpy In the mean they work slowly or they don't respond friendly in the friendly manner
and they may not even answered. And so you can perceive that as bumpiness the machines can be grumpy. Yes.
You also say just so of course one.
So the robot make errors like humans do these things machines when there is a machine error.
You might see a blue screen and just says machine error for four and that is not very friendly.
We cannot have robots do that because machines are bound to make heiress.
There's not going to be a perfect machine the never makes errors.
Just like humans is no he pretty human will never makes any mistakes.
It is important for empathetic machine to apologise like humans do because that will keep the communication Smoove
there will keep the conversation continue with. Human user because I think it's kind of Indeed.
Yes it is most important to keep the conversation smooth and the. Human robot communication skills.
So it's just that she's feeling happy that Cory Booker.
I think humans issue feel happy
when they are communicating with the robot at least they can few related to the robot friendly in a friendly sort of
way it is important for humans to feel that you understand in order for us to trust the robot to work with the robot
will be Philip we have a sort of character but develop character because if you're going around the characters
or your mom.
So
when we built a third to robots were very careful in also designing the robot personality because what we call our robot
personality.
So the beginning we would be designing a personality so this is similar to a human predisposed you know personality
we're born with. But as we go along. We also let the robot learn personality from data.
So from a particular personality type for example a robot can imitate a particular person's personality type over time
by observing how that person communicates with other people.
So a robot can also be nurtured into developing its a personality. So you have this question for each word. Yes.
What about rogue robot also there is a nature and nurture so nature
or robot nature comes from our laboratories A comes from the design of robot by humans by engineers.
That's the nature that's where robot comes out of the lab and that robot has that personality but then.
Since robots have machine learning algorithms in them they were also learned from you know a particular kind of you
know they will learn from their environment and then they will continue to develop their personality.
For example if at the beginning we ensure that the robot is not racist
and that is a pretty s'posed you know what we designed in the beginning and over time
when the robots see is whatever's out in the world.
There can be racist comments and all that but the robot will reject that.
And then we'll know absorb that into the robots personality the robot will make a judgment to say that oh that is
racist and I should now learn that much.
Just because at the beginning you know at the beginning we need to teach you about values
and personality doesn't work because. Yes so so so the people who work on robots.
We all have this responsibility we're like parents to robots.
You know parents or children we indeed do at the beginning we do teach our robots in certain ways with certain code
and then we let them run very much like how we how we nurture our children when they reach adulthood.
We just let them go. You fat. When they're younger we send them to school.
So we don't always teach them everything ourselves we send them to school with
and our in the world they learn from the environment. So that's what we do with robots. Could you talk a little bit.
It's becoming. So. Rover is.
So we're building robots to be a little bit more like us more like a person indeed because humans can communicate with
other another human being better. We cannot ask humans to speak the robot language. So we need a robot to speak.
I want to guage understand us. So and why. That the personality thing the robot values.
You know that is all necessary in order for us to communicate with a robot better. Self.
If I can think about myself to think about it so.
The robot can certainly be taught to think about itself yes or has shows the behavior of thinking about itself.
Meaning that robot can simulate the behavior of somebody with who is thinking about itself whether there's
consciousness within the robot we don't know because we don't understand consciousness.
That's what we're saying you can program it. Group. It's not always preprogrammed there are certain things.
So this is what I was trying to say with preprogramed machine learning way.
So would probably preprogramed robots to learn. Right. Just like humans also preprogrammed to learn.
So that part of it's preprogramed as the what what we call nature.
And then the preprograming also allows the robot to learn to pick up from the physical world from interacting with
human beings furder knowledge and further personality could be one of them. Can we monitor them.
You know I mean we monitor people to help people not behave like that I am sure that if so deferral boss different
depending on the purposes so if they are supposed to take care of patients
and they make mistakes then withing there's going to be there is must be a machine era.
Then we would check the machine would check the code and try to spot that era.
We don't really punish robot per se at this point but it can be imagined in some learning algorithms working corporate.
It. What is a reward and what is punishment so that they learn proper things.
But for example there's a question about which cars responsible to come close the second question because they are so
if they accidentally harm somebody your you said you know robot you shouldn't do that
and they should learn from that punishment.
Perhaps not like human punishment I don't think you know we're going to head there all by the robot would feel you know
it's not not that kind of punishment but it's in the algorithm that there's a cost function.
Whether it's doing the right thing or not there will be a cost function of positive and negative values
or strange terms. Well how other strains is to have. My memory.
My sense
or sensory abilities my intelligence my emotional intelligence whatever it is all be downloaded to a robot of with
enjoy a body and then the robot will continue functioning as me
when I'm no longer in this world you want to make up your first I want to make a copy of myself very interesting.
I think that to some extent we're already doing that but given I'm not sure it's feasible within my lifetime
but I think it is feasible the robot will have you know will be equipped with our work perception abilities
and our intelligence our emotional intelligence and our ability to learn.
And the robot you know there are people who are building a robot. With really human like form.
With you know very lifelike skin
and I know that we put this together the robot will have the body would be a body in the. Human like body.
So they will pick up signals from the world as we do so.
That is I think that is feasible and I'm not saying that there will be me.
There will be just a copy of me and there would not necessarily have the conscience of me.
I'm not talking about me living forever. I'm talking about a copy what would be well would it be very good question.
A copy just an enjoy the copy of of a human what book you want to.
So it would do what I would do under given circumstances.
For example maybe you can go on lecture in the university teach students.
It can learn from from the world and maybe it can perform research. It can be other robots but it won't be me.
It will be a copy of me but it just so it's quite hard.
I know I know we don't know what consciousness is it's almost a philosophical question Is question consciousness does
exist. Once we have all of this kind of sensory input intelligence and learning in place.
Would there be a point where and there is indeed a consciousness.
I don't know I don't know we don't know what consciousness is and work comes from philosophers that say that.
Finally I think so yes indeed I think so.
I am indeed indeed a robot can conclude that and
but even then the robot can have the behavior of someone with consciousness
and we still don't know whether that robot really has this Minas you know this self-consciousness. If you look into it.
Five years. What. If you could really fight here it would look like.
So in terms of eight years I believe there will be robots.
Not all robots some robots will look just like us they would talk just like us and behave just like us.
It's possible in twenty five years they can move and gesture is actually like humans and.
Some of these robots these are core enjoys will be very very.
You cannot tell the difference between them and humans
and then there are the robots we still need other robots to help us other robotic machines like the vacuum cleaner the
vacuum cleaner now going to have a human head there will be kind of creepy.
So we still have other robots there don't look like humans. So there will be a variety of robots around among us.
Your work to make it work. Some people feel frightened.
Some people question why robots need to be more human like they think.
Then they will be challenging us or taking over us. Others like especially children think it's just really cool.
They want to they can no way for that to happen.
So I think depending on the culture of people come from them what they expect of machines.
They have different reactions but for the most part for example I talk to doctors medical doctors
and they love the idea they're robots who have empathy to put towards patients so they can better take care of patients
you measure people. Some how much. Some people already scared. Some people already sick scared of robots.
I think when people see robots become more human like they magine all sorts of things
and I think one reason is there has been too many science fiction movies there patrol robots as threatening and.
Menacing butt. That's just science fiction and people should be people should not be. Swayed by by fiction.
You know drinking on a reality. We're building robots to help people.
Nobody's building robots to purposely destroy human kindness that kind of thing because I think part worked that Palin.
In we were trying to build robots that would be friendly indeed to have robots have empathy.
Then they would never harm people right. So that's why I'm perceived as important.
And if they do have empathy they were never heard us. By the three one question the Three Laws of Robotics.
I don't remember all of them but actually one of them asked help to help people not to harm. You're in the.
So one of the Three Laws of Robotics is to for robots help people
and I think all the robotics is working on robots today are trying to do that people start to see if you're friendly.
I hope so. I hope people will see robots as friends because they're friendly.
If we can see robots as friends then we can trust them to help us. And the French for companionship how.
We hope robots we're building robots to be people's companion to be companions to children to be companion to to the
elderly when they're lonely and all that but like all machines the hardware deteriorates right so your i Phone
or your smartphone
or you might buy the next generation smartphone so robots are we going to have a robot there last for ever.
I don't thing. Right now that's the purpose. So you might have the next generation of the same robot.
But they're about will have the same personality as the first robot and will have the memory. So yeah.
In that sense you can have a robot companion forever but the body my my have to be changed from time to time.
If you want coverage. So the intelligence of robot is completely software based.
So we can make multiple copies of the same software.
We can't have the same robot same personality same memory in different. Bodies.
So we kept multiple robots that sound the same behave the same and do the same thing.
Copyright and copy copy experience because the software there is. So how people love their genes like they love cars.
I think people will love their robots if the robots are friendly and pathetic. Have a sense of humor.
Who would love them.
People who love them like they love their motorcycles in their car see and indeed
but they also my want to have multiple robots you know a different version with a different personality just like some
people like multiple cars of different styles think they're your record. So I think people are prepared.
We've already seen men on the moon forty fifty years ago and this is high time we see robots allows us
and I think people are ready for a bus as long as they're friendly. If you don't budget.
You're actually OK which part and intentional language actually is a little bit.
So what we're doing is for example use the example of humor as I explained before humor comes from not just the words
you use but the tone of voice and even your your your your facial expressions. So the same words express in.
And contacts can be humorous and humorous. So what we do is we programmed machines to have learning algorithms.
So they learn from watching a lot of comedy shows for example and You Tube videos
and figure out what what humorous So next time somebody says something humorous the machine will know
and to be able to laugh voice.
How do they know it's funny from learning from so in the learning algorithms
and they bought the machines to see examples many many examples millions of sentences.
You know a lot of thousands and tens of thousands of T.V. Shows where people laugh.
So for example humor consists of you know how do you tell a joke. Usually there's a trigger.
There's a set up there's a trigger and the punchline.
So machines were in the machine was see that in all these comedy shows like humans do.
And then they will pick up you know when there will be a punch line and they know that is humor
and the over the machine algorithm learning our more use currently is what was coming in know was deep learning
algorithm. So how do you.
So we use a machine learning to teach robot to learn about our emotions sentiments including humor machine learning
there are two kinds of machine learning approaches one is what we call supervised learning the other is unsupervised
supervised learning we actually give machines examples and we have them.
We have the data and notated by humans humans says look this is a sentence that humorous.
This isn't is there's a punchline for a joke and this is where people laugh.
So that's cos a proviso learning machine learn from that to have a sense of humor as supervised learning is more like
how humans learn.
We don't tell the machine explicitly this is a human it is not humorous and we just give a lot of data.
For the machine to learn from context. So the unsupervised learning is really were.
We hope to achieve in the future because if machine can't have unsupervised learning.
Then we don't need human explicitly teaching machines all the time. This is humor.
This is happiness and other so that was save a lot of effort from from the humanities
and supervised learning is harder though because it will require a lot of general learning abilities
and general deduction abilities induction and I believe it will require machines to have sensory input to know how.
So conscious of scientists I've been studying how humans learn.
So they believe that humans have of course we have we're born with some kind of learning abilities innate
when babies are born they already know how to they already know how to recognise their mothers for faces
and voices they already picking up from ten months in their mother's tummy just. Do we know people.
We don't know exactly how we are and supervise we're trying to model that.
So another side of working on robots is that
when we want to build robots to be more human like we have Bill models of human thinking.
So as we research on how to make robots to have a sense of humor. We understand human sense of humor better.
So as we learn. As the machine we learn we also learn how we function.
So we don't know exactly how we how we how we learn
and surprise words fashion for which trying to to to to research on that. That's a.
That's a very important research direction.
So I mean there's a lot of talk about artificial and what condition of artificial.
So the condition of artificial intelligence we are trying to work in towards the what some people call strongly I would
say is a general purpose system or general purpose robot.
Today we're only working we're still only working on a single purpose or multipurpose robots that can do one task.
You know heard of you know of our goal beating the World Champion go
and their systems there can you know lift heavy weights and assemble cars. These are single purpose robotic systems.
So we're working towards a general purpose robotic system they can really be your companion take care of people in that
case then they're Obama's have intelligence to be more human like and for humane colleges
and pathy is indispensable in must recognize not just in what people are saying
but how people are saying what you truly mean.
So empathy is important you motion the intelligence is a huge part of human intelligence. You should just mention.
Without I think it would cannot call a system
or robot human like intelligent without without empathy is that what it's like because it's has been lacking in our
discussion of building AI systems for the last thirty years but it's coming now and.
I'm happy to say that I've been talking about her
and some other researchers also working on this because you're working. Years and working on this.
That is a new direction and people in general agree with with this direction.
So yeah there are researchers working towards this goal as well there's agreement in terms of that free. Work.
Something. I think people are afraid of the unknown people always afraid of the UNO.
I think if you if we go back in time in one nine hundred fifty S.
and Describe today's internet and smart smartphones and how we use them
and how we can get access to good material as well as bad material at your fingertips.
We told people in the fifty's about this today they will also be very very afraid.
What happens is that we adapt to technology just like a technology adaptors I dabs to ask.
So it doesn't happen overnight
and we've been living without a vision Teligent for a long time already starting with all those are dramatic
calculators and then you know we are all we would take an airplane with
or without you know being afraid that it's being flown by a computer actually so we've been living with artificial
intelligence for a long time.
It's just you know gradually we're going to get used to pollution of such intelligent machines they will gradually be
able to talk to us and they will gradually be able to empathise with our feelings
and they will gradually will be able to do more to help us all get used to step by step. It doesn't happen overnight.
But what we ought to show. That's what fish. Robert. I mean we are called you talk about robots with heart.
Can you talk a little bit more about.
Yes So with empathy in the robot a robot would never behave and learn and and understand like a human being.
So without empathy.
I would say that the robot will not be human like
and I'm told will be limited thing is most important to our discussion about the artificial.
The entire discussion about of intelligence does include that today and I'm one of the people who would champion it
and and in general there's a general agreement that it is needed
but a vision to fight a vision TELEGIN that people work on different components of artificial intelligence
and those of us working on the emotional recognition.
Certainly see this as our our job to make that happen to make robots have empathy.
If you look further for future reference communication is not a good start.
Or whatsoever larger than your old mind for me to do so much. So yes. What's interesting today.
What's happening already. Is that my mind and your mind are no longer limited from by our own life experience. If you.
You know twenty years ago I wouldn't know how to respond to a lot of questions way that I'm not an expert in
but today anybody with access to the Internet and we computer can tell you a lot of things about a specific topic.
So our human mind and how human knowledge has evolved. We're already connected to this vast network of minds.
So you can pull up You Tube video to learn how to cook any any kind of food you can pull up a computer page to learn
about any particular technical topic or political topic of some history
and that happens isn't Taney Asli So is that part of my mind already. Or is part of the world.
We already are connected. So in the future when robots and hence our physical abilities.
They were also and hence our mental abilities. When that happens there would be basically on top of the Internet.
We have access to will also have this robot and has our ability to understand the knowledge.
And so there was that would be another layer of intelligence the hands of human intelligence. Just like today.
There's a robotic system thing help people who cannot walk walk. Those S.
or Skeleton robots they can help people become stronger physically robots can also
and our intelligence to to enable us to know more to be able to do more and think better with the help of the robots.
You can explain more. What you mean.
So to Bill robots with all the components of humane Teligent human learning abilities human perception human memory
and human judgment. Human values.
So a long list of this things my wildest dream will be able to do that and teach that to a robot
and for example for a robot to copy all of that from me
and my personal experience my memory my judgment my values which evolve as well so.
It's a it's it's like a copy of of a person of me and I when I'm not around that copy will continue.
Maybe we'll continue to talk to my children.
Talk to my children's children but they know it's not me you know the normal me but it's a copy
but there will be interesting to replicate. Before I die so and I see where it's really not. A replica a replicant.
You know you think a run. I'm a huge fan of player and.
Yeah my wildest dream will have replicants But rebel guns also know there are click
and they don't they don't fool people into thinking they're human beings. I mean what if it doesn't have to be me.
It can be anybody but if you calculate your. Yes.
What would you think I mean I don't know I'm curious to know I don't know that happened without being me
or that be just a copy of me I considered today weak.
We have people who can build a robot that physically looks like me writing exactly a copy of me
but intelligence wise and memory
and all that it's not because it's new it's still very very far from being a complete copy of it after a real human
being. So if we have a more almost perfect copy. Would there still be just the copy I think is just a copy.
It's not me. It's not so much or no. It would be my avatar. I was there would be my avatar.
There would be Avatar and physical and mental level best to an avatar not to the real me. Maybe you can do the task.
I can do.
I don't know maybe you can continue to teach it will be an avatar would be something like three
or forty photographs for you at your current I'm actually thinking it's going to be a physical body with very human
like skin them very human like everything. There are people working on building that.
So I think that's entirely possible in twenty years the body is possible but the mind.
You know because we don't understand the mind completely.
So how you know component by component module by Miller module we're building the mind into the robot
and today we're still talking about service robots at home robots that do particular tasks.
And we're still not building a general purpose human like robot like a replicant we're not doing that yet
and we don't have an interest a specific interest in doing that it would be more like a scientific pursue because we
don't know what we need why do we need a general purpose robot that's exactly like me was the fun in the application of
that there's no applications at that
but that would be that will serve us like a scientific quest rather than engineering.
You know application rather than a commercial purpose scientific quest as I mentioned earlier when we study a robot
when we model intelligence for robot we're also modeling human intelligence.
We're studying humans at the same time and that is interesting to me.
So people want to watch you know if somebody were with.
But you know many people who work our division encourages our huge science fiction fan.
We're just naturally attracted with science fiction's if we were young
and then we got into this area because of that any of us are many. You had to make into reality.
And I think it's fair to say that a lot of our imagination are shaped by a science fiction. We grew up with.
And so you will see things that look science fiction like and there's not a coincidence just were shaped by that.